My name is Janina Loh, and I'm working at
the University of Vienna as a post doc in
the field of philosophy of technology and
media, and specialized in robot ethics and
responsibility research and transposed humanism.
I'm not afraid of autonomous vehicles.
I'm just a little bit worried because I think
that people misinterpret the challenges and
the problems that come along with developing
autonomous vehicles.
When I sit on panel discussions on these topics
one of the first questions is always "will
machines run over the world" and this dystopian
"Terminator" scenario.
Another question arises like "we're going
to be wonderful, and we will merge with nanobots
and upload our mind on a computer, and be
virtually immortal!"
So we always have these extreme scenarios,
like the dystopian scenario on the one hand,
and the utopian scenario on the other hand.
And I think it's much more complicated than
that.
It's not that easy.
We don't have the luxury to choose either
a black or a white scenario.
We have to get in the messy grey area that
is in between.
And we have to look at concrete artificial
technological developments.
So I am not a prophet!
I'm not but a philosopher and it's my responsibility
to figure out the challenges that go along
with each and every technological development.
And not jump on the train of a dystopian vision
or a utopian vision.